Research fraud refers to cases where data
were either fabricated or falsified to provide
false support for the researcher's hypothesis.
Fabrication means the data were never collected,
but were made up.
Falsification means existing data were illegitimately
altered including manipulating research materials,
images, data, equipment, or processes.
Falsification also includes changing or omitting
data or results in such a way that the research
is not accurately represented.
For example, a person might falsify data to
make it fit with the desired end result of
a study.
In 1998, physician Andrew Wakefield published
a study in The Lancet, claiming that his research
indicated a connection between autism and
the measles-mumps-rubella vaccine.
This research was highly respected and undermined
public confidence in the vaccine, leading
to many parents refusing the shot.
Ultimately, this led to increases in the number
of cases of measles and mumps in the U.S.
and Europe, with some areas reporting very
dangerous and widespread outbreaks.
When faced with an investigation in 2010,
it was revealed that Wakefield and his colleagues
had altered facts about the children in their
study, and Wakefield had even been paid off
by a lawyer planning to sue the manufacturer
of the vaccine.
The British General Medical Council found
Wakefield guilty of fraud and misconduct.
In 2006, Korean researcher Hwang Woo-suk was
found to have fabricated a series of experiments
in stem cell research, a field in which he
was once considered one of the pioneering
experts.
He was previously famous for his two Science
journal articles in which he reported success
in creating human embryonic stem cells through
cloning, but is now infamous for his massive
case of fraud and scientific misconduct after
it was revealed that much of his stem cell
research had been faked.
Hwang was charged with embezzlement and bioethics
law violations, for which he was sentenced
to a two-year suspended prison sentence and
barred from engaging in stem cell research
by the South Korean government, as well as
fired from his position with Seoul National
University.
However, Hwang continues to lead research
in creating embryonic stem cell lines from
cloned pig embryos, and his lab has been actively
publishing manuscripts on PubMed.
In January 2014, Haruko Obokata from the Riken
Center for Developmental Biology in Kobe,
Japan, published 2 papers describing the method,
called stimulus-triggered acquisition of pluripotency
in Nature.
But they were retracted in July after Nature
discovered that the papers included plagiarized
writing, misidentified images, and misreported
data.
Haruko Obokata, the lead author, who performed
the studies and wrote the manuscripts, was
found guilty of falsifying data.
Biologist Yoshiki Sasai, leader of the Riken
research group, was a co-author on both papers.
He was criticized for his poor supervision.
During the investigation, Sasai committed
suicide at the Riken Center.
In 2016, a group of researchers from University
Malaya was found to duplicate the images of
cells in the photos contained in their research
article.
The researchers were later found to have published
the same results 3 times, in three different
journals.
The authors are almost all from Malaysia,
and not the same on these three publications.
Yet, all three papers have same two corresponding
authors Sekaran Muniandy, a professor at the
Department Of Molecular Medicine at the University
of Malaya in Kuala Lumpur, and the first author,
his PhD student, Nima Samie.
Overall, academic fraud is rare, which makes
it all the more shocking when a major case
is uncovered.
To the public, it may seem mind-boggling that
scientists would go to such lengths to deceive.
In an ideal world, scientists work together
to make incremental discoveries that add to
the body of knowledge in a field and are recognized
for quality work.
In reality, the world of science can be cutthroat
and isolating, with little oversight.
Stem cell research is certainly not the only
research field with a fraud problem, but it
has all the right elements to motivate dishonesty.
It’s a cutting-edge field with the potential
to discover treatments for human diseases.
It attracts highly competitive people who
are all scrambling to make the next big discovery.
And that discovery must be made, written,
and published before any competitors can catch
up.
Add that to an academic culture that places
ever-rising pressure on researchers to churn
out publications in order to land jobs or
tenure, especially publications in high-impact
journals like Nature and Science, and you
begin to see why researchers resort to cutting
corners or massaging their data.
In 2014, Nobel Prize winner Randy Schekman
spoke out against publishing in prestigious
journals, saying that they contributed to
unhealthy research practices, and advised
people to boycott them.
Barring acceptance at a major journal, academics
must still publish somewhere, and this pressure
has created a market for yet another type
of academic fraud, predatory journals.
Both fabrication and falsification are serious
forms of misconduct because they result in
a scientific record that does not accurately
reflect observed truth.
First of all, the scientific literature is
contaminated with false empirical data.
This alone holds back scientific progress.
Researchers might pursue a line of research
that seems promising, but is in fact baseless.
Honest researchers see their projects fail
to replicate promising results.
They might incorrectly conclude this is due
to their personal lack of research skills.
The project might be abandoned without the
failed replications ever coming to light.
Secondly, precious funding resources that
could have been spent on valid avenues of
research are spent on fraudulent research
and related projects that build on it, but
are in fact less promising then they seem.
Thirdly, once fraud is exposed, the reputation
and credibility of the field, including the
majority of researchers who do have integrity,
is severely damaged.
This can result in more difficulty to obtain
funding in a general area where fraud has
been exposed.
This puts honest researchers who had the bad
luck to be in a related field at a disadvantage.
Fraud cases are invariably accompanied by
reluctance or even unwillingness to share
data and research information with others.
Unless researchers are challenged or even
required to be open and transparent, fraud
can be tempting in an academic climate where
publishing positive, confirmatory results
is held in high regard.
Certain instances of fraud can be easy to
spot.
For example, if a referee knows for a fact
that a particular laboratory does not have
the facilities to conduct the research that
was published.
Or, if it's obvious an image looks manipulated
or is made up from several different experiments.
The data from the control experiments might
be "too perfect".
In such situations, an investigation would
be conducted to determine if an act of fraud
was committed.
To help prevent fraud, most publishers have
strict policies on manipulation of images
and access to the reported data.
In general, digital image enhancement is acceptable.
However, a positive relationship between the
original data and the resulting image must
be maintained to avoid creating unrepresentative
data or the loss of meaningful signals.
No specific feature within an image may be
enhanced, obscured, moved, removed, or introduced.
Adjustments of brightness, contrast, or color
balance are usually acceptable as long as
they do not obscure or eliminate any information
present in the original.
If a figure has been significantly manipulated,
you must note the nature of the enhancements
in the figure legend or in the 'Materials
and Methods' section.
Authors may also be asked to provide the raw
data in connection with a paper for editorial
review.
Therefore, all data for a specific paper should
be retained for a reasonable time after publication.
There should be named custodian for the data.
Studies undertaken in human beings, e.g. clinical
trials have specific guidelines about the
duration of data retention.
What about unintentional error that comes
across as misconduct?
According to the U.S. Office of Research Integrity,
research misconduct does not include honest
error or differences of opinion.
But, it's best never to have the integrity
of your work come into question.
As a researcher and author, it is essential
to understand what constitutes appropriate
data management, including data collection,
retention, analysis and reporting, in accordance
with responsible conduct of research.